I mean, have you seen the, the new, uh, theme park.
That released
[inaudible] I saw a picture of that and I thought, wow,
Lego lands really improved. I didn't think it was real at first.
I usually hate amusement parks, but first time I'm like, yeah, I'm gone.
You want to go now before it's opens up to tourists? Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Gotta be hell.
But knowing Japan is going to be another lottery to get those tickets.
And I hate that. I talked about that. I don't think we've talked about that.
So I watched the video of, uh, uh, what's the guy's name.
I should get him a motto, like having a tour of it.
And you get like a, a bracelet you can like hit with.
And like there's like keys and stopped really? Do he looks bad. Like,
I felt like a ten-year-old watching him talk about it.
Sorry. I started Japanese YouTuber who got like first access ever as [inaudible]
, but he's also been the Jack, but he's been sponsored by USDA
and Nintendo in the past.
She's literally like, Japan's like YouTube. Oh, he cooking. Yeah. Yeah.
Because one time the like either policemen that was asked to be like,
what do you do? And I was like, YouTube. It he's like, Oh, like he in like, no,
no, like he got canned. I'm like, yeah. He khaki man. Like, yeah, dude. Yeah.
Whatever, like he could kill on YouTube.
Yeah. Pretty much strange. But uh, yeah. What the we've never talked about.
Right? So this is how you get tickets in Japan basically. Yeah.
I explain that it's better than scalping. The scalpel, scalping, scalping,
scalping, scalping is people who buy a ton of things.
Oh, no people do that too. I mean,
it's just in theory to stop that from happening. Right. But like,
for example, the, when the Olympics, uh,
we don't know if that's going to be happening next year, but uh.
We announced that it will be. Yeah, we'll see.
I reckon it will happen no matter what,
but it'd be interesting to see how bell does it.
Yeah, exactly. But like with the Olympics, for example, they did a,
it's so dumb.
So they do a lottery that you enter and it's like a lottery to get a
certain amount of tickets. So this is how we do it. So like, uh,
when I went to the persona five, uh, concert, yeah, it was a lottery system,
but it was really weird because it was like,
you go into the lottery to get a certain number of tickets and
they're different lottery. So it's like, if you want to go just by yourself,
you enter the lottery to get one ticket,
but there's another lottery to get two tickets or three tickets or four tickets.
And just because you enter into one of them,
it's not guaranteed that you're going to get those tickets. Yeah.
But then what it is is that you might think, Oh, okay.
So if you win the lottery, then you just get the tickets, right. No,
you get the right to purchase the tickets.
Japan have figured out a way to get your fight. Every process possible, man.
Yeah. I mean, it's also, I also saw that you could get some of the tickets,
but you could only be entered into some of them if you bought like a Panasonic
device. Yeah.
They were like giving away some of the tickets to cause I was like, what the?
And also, and also the thing, as well as that,
like say you into the lottery to get four tickets. Right.
But you're not sure if you're going to get it.
So you want to enter multiple times,
but here's the kicker for say you win twice. Right.
In that FortiGate lottery. You're forced to pay for those eight tickets.
You can't back out of that. Like you're actually forced.
Like even if it's only four people that you're going with just did another
lottery for backup. You have to buy eight tickets. It's just,
it just doesn't make sense to me. It just doesn't make sense. I,
I understand in theory why they do it, but I feel like this is this.
This is like trying to put out a fire with cooking oil. You know what I mean?
It's just the most roundabout. Time-consuming way to do it.
And I guaranteed Nintendo. Lion's going to do the same thing.
Yeah. Probably. I mean, Nintendo, I haven't got the best rep.
They've been like everything up. I believe that bad.
Nintendo and DMC like that right now.
With the stuff with the smash tournament. Did you see that as well?
That was a while back. Did you not see that? No, I didn't see that basically.
They're like just a cease and desist in a big tournament that been going on for
a while and everyone was like the cause they were using. Um,
so the, obviously the net code of the switch smash brothers is pretty garbage.
Yeah. So people fan model their own version of it. That's much better. Oh,
it's called like Slippy or something. And they didn't allow that.
And because they were going to use that called slipping because it like actually
runs smoothly because Nintendo online sucks and always has sucked.
And the fact that they pay for it is kind of a jerk. Yeah.
Cause you don't really get anything out of it. Like it's awful. It's so bad.
Like I love Nintendo, but God is that online SOC um, so they,
they cease and desist at them and then they were also sponsoring a Splatoon
tournament. Right. And guess what? Guess what the prize was for the,
so they were giving the prize like sanctioned event.
They they're giving the top prize for a team of five versus five was a $25
Nintendo.
Oh my God. Dead.
They, they D they canceled the event.
Cause one of the teams had something like free smash or something was like,
like had something along the lines of like the tender cause solidarity with the
smash bros.
Prize. You can't even pay
split that can't even pay for the game tournament. Is it.
Because it's like, for some reason, intelligence wants their IPS to die. Okay.
Right. Games are sweating, man. Those are just like, Oh,
there's a new competitor in e-sports now.
It's eyes wild to me. Cause you just see the,
like the complete difference again, like you said, riot, right? Yeah.
And you have the, what is it?
The Baron Pat red bull pass the red bull power Mercedes drive to victory
fully embracing, like becoming sports and their tenders. Like none of that.
The state farm analyst desk.
I remember watching worlds this year and it was so weird just seeing like
literally everything monitored, watching, drinking my G out of my
G feel for sponsoring trash tastes.
Yeah. It is.
It is funny how it's become like American football where like every single part
of the game is like sponsored. And then you, again,
you have the complete opposite, right. Then 10 tenders. Like, yeah,
we don't want to put any of this because there's a ton of could make money off
it if they really wanted to, there'll be in charge of this.
But I just have no interest in it. No, I mean.
I mean, they're probably already making enough as he is or.
But he's mindset, isn't it? You like,
we've made enough doing it the way we like, we don't want to make more money.
Yeah. Like I guess, which is so odd for a business to say,
because I think what was it like last year tender was the most cash rich company
in Japan. Yeah. Which is insane.
I, I think there's something is slightly wrong with that statement.
It's not that they don't want to make more money. Cause I've,
I've from like my experience working with Japanese money, uh,
Japanese companies, they want to make as much money as possible,
but they only want to make as much money as possible using the methods.
They like, they don't want to make money.
It's that they don't know how to make money.
Exactly. Exactly. Because they're like, he, he sports. I think
someone like, you know, if you asked me Connor, you can make $10 guaranteed.
What kind of,
you can make a hundred dollars by pushing yourself and being a little crazy.
And it might, it might, might go horribly wrong. Of course,
every time I'm going to be like a hundred bucks, let's do it. Yeah. Of course.
By the Japanese companies, don't say it that way. Yeah.
Nintendo Japanese companies like, yeah.
There's one person in the company that wants to get creative,
but he has to ask 60 other people for yes.
And that might take awhile time that you always say, yeah,
a new trends come out.
I get it. Because almost, you know, if you're the, you're the, these companies,
you don't want to get, make a hundred out. People lose that job. Yeah.
The safe route. But sometimes the safe route can just lead to being stagnated.
It's like, how detrimental could it be? If one thing doesn't work out, right?
Like again, Nintendo is the most cash rich company in Japan. Right? It's like,
how much do they have.
The lose? It sucks. Cause you just, everyone like wants Nintendo to just do my.
Cause everyone loves. Everyone wants to like scene into everything.
Hearing from Nintendo just to do the right thing. You know what I mean?
It's literally.
The opposite of like EA where everyone just wants to keep up and keep up to the
point where laws have to be made. But with Nintendo,
everyone just wants to see then it's, it's like in the sh you know,
you have those typical shows where, you know,
the brother is addicted to drugs and the whole family is super nice.
And it's like, come on, just please stop. Just come on and get,
get back on your feet, man. Okay. Especially in attendance,
how many chances do we have to give you?
How many rehabs do we need to put you through to see you get back on track.
After all the W's that they will take in these last couple of.
Days, it was just like, kill it. Every.
[Inaudible] everyone was like, yep. Nintendo King. Yeah, exactly.
everybody else. And now they're just like, we haven't done the nail.
Let's give it a couple of people, lost their.
When they brought out literal cardboard, like,
like this is a company that can release cardboard and we'll eat it up. Like,
this is how much we want. I completely forgot about that. Yeah.
Like the day they do like the coolest,
like they don't the contender or just doing their own thing, man.
Like I played ring fit and I was like,
what kind of crackhead came up with this idea to like just exercise with a ring
and like it, and it works and it's good. This is insane.
I would never see this from any other company. It seems like creatively.
They will take anything.
Risk possible, but like on a business sense, they're like, no, no,
we do not do business here. We only, we only make things.
Business is not allowed.